als hätte die atomindustrie unserem
planeten nicht genug vermüllte soll ein
schwimmendes atomkraftwerk den
strahlenden müll wohl über den ganzen
planeten verteilt ich gebe zu dass das
polemisch ist aber ich finde es echt zu
treffen das video ist übrigens in
zusammenarbeit mit technology review
entstanden und am ende bekommt er einen
gratis heft der wirklich coolen
zeitschrift geschenkt ging es ums tanzen
fiction herzlich willkommen ich finde
dass wenn es um gift geht man ruhig
polemisch werden darf stickoxide
feinstaub umweltgifte sie alle töten
menschen und das ist schlecht man darf
das verurteilen und die gefahren beim
namen nennen und das gilt auch für die
kernkraft spätestens seit fukushima
wissen wir was das für eine furchtbare
solche ist und das dürfen wir auch so
sagen atomkraftwerke sind unsicher
gefährlich und schicken mit ihrem abfall
dem tod in die welt unbestritten und
jetzt kommt's 144 meter lang und 30
meter breit ist der prototyp mit dem
namen akademik lomonossow eines
schwimmenden atomkraftwerks zwei
reaktionen mit jeweils 35 megawatt
elektrischer leistung finden auf dem
schwimmenden kernkraftwerk platz rein
rechnerisch könnte damit eine stadt mit
200.000 einwohnern mit strom versorgt
werden spannend vor allem für entlegene
regionen dieser welt als äußerst riskant
bezeichnen kritiker und kritikerinnen
das ganze projekt die befürworter
dagegen verweisen auf die weltweite
nachfrage und bezeichnen die
schwimmenden atomkraftwerke als
klimafreundliche alternative zur kohle
im mai wurde die akademik lomonossow im
hafen von st petersburg der
öffentlichkeit präsentiert ende juli
begann die beladung des schwimmenden
atomkraftwerks im moment das war in
sankt petersburg an massiven
bürgerprotesten gescheitert mit diesem
schritt steht fest eine neue art der
dezentralen energieversorgung ist
möglich wenn er mich fragt ist das eine
äußerst fragwürdige entwicklung in den
zeiten in denen die meisten anderen
länder atomkraftwerke stilllegen
doch die technologie dafür ist nicht neu
schon seit vielen jahren nämlich tragen
u-boote eisbrecher und flugzeugträger
kleine kernreaktoren durch die meere
hinter dem prototypen akademik
lomonossow steckt die russische
atomenergie agentur rosatom
ihr plan ist
es vor allem entlegene regionen durch
das schwimmende atomkraftwerk mit strom
zu versorgen
zu der elektrischen leistung von 35
megawatt der beiden reaktoren kommt noch
eine thermische leistung von etwa 150
megawatt im kommenden jahr soll die
akademik lomonossow nach per
weggeschleppt werden das ist eine
nautische siedlung etwa 350 kilometer
nördlich des polarkreises gelegen lautet
seine mission die russische bohrinseln
mit strom zu versorgen ebenso wie die
5000 einwohner und zwar sowohl mit strom
als auch mit wärme
der langfristige plan der russen ist
aber somit an die großen gas und
ölvorkommen in der aktiven region zu
kommen kein wirklich einfaches vorhaben
denn in den entsprechenden regionen kann
es durchaus mal bis zu minus 60 grad
celsius werden sprich je geht es gar
nicht um klimaneutrale energieversorgung
sondern genau um das gegenteil ziemlich
pervers das ganze direktoren bestehen
aus brennstäben mit niedrig
angereichertem uran die zu 20 prozent
aus uran 235 anteil bestehen mit den
druckwasserreaktoren ist man laut
rosatom auf der sicheren seite denn
diese wurden schon auf den
atomeisbrecher der time klasse erprobt
so sollen auch schwere stürme erdbeben
der stärke 10 oder tsunamis dem
prototypen nichts anhaben können
ein weiterer sicherheitsaspekt
direktorin befinden sich in
sicherheitsbehältern die mit wasser
geflutet sind in kombination mit dem
pumpen des aktiven kühlsystems soll
dadurch im worst case eine kernschmelze
verhindert werden
die zirkulation des wassers soll nach
angaben von rosatom
aber selbst bei einem ausfall aller
kühlpumpen schlimmeres verhindern und
die brennstäbe für 24 stunden kühlen
doch nicht alle experten und expertinnen
sind davon überzeugt so etwa auch der
atom energie experte von greenpeace hans
vital ein atomkraftwerk ohne beton
schutzhülle dazu auf einem schwimmenden
ponton im stürmischen arktische meer
unter widrigsten witterungsbedingungen
dass es wirklich riskant denn das
eindämmen einer drohenden kernschmelze
könnte alleine aus logistischen gründen
nicht garantiert werden falls ich
nämlich der atom ponton bei einem sturm
beispielsweise losreißen würde wäre er
ohne eigenen antrieb manövrierunfähig
und was würde im fall eines
terroranschlages passieren
das russische energieunternehmen dagegen
stützt sich darauf dass die reaktoren
klimafreundlicher sein als die
versorgung durch kohle
naja aber das hatten wir gerade
schließlich würden wir ohne direkten
kohlendioxidausstoß kommen aber dafür
verantwortlich sein
mehr treibhaus relevante ressourcen zu
fördern und natürlich stecken auch große
wirtschaftliche interessen dahinter
denn wie eben schon angedeutet könnten
solche schwimmenden atomkraftwerke
der strategische schlüssel dafür sein
die aktivregion auszubeuten dazu der
direktor von rosatom alexejew wir
erwarten großes interesse insbesondere
von inselstaaten wo sich die entwicklung
einer zentralisierten
energieinfrastruktur schwierig gestaltet
und die russischen atomkraftwerke auf
see haben tatsächlich weltweit schon
großes interesse ausgelöst
beispielsweise bei den ländern
argentinien malaysia und indonesien
übrigens sind die russen nicht die
einzigen die diese technologie zukünftig
verstärkt einsetzen wollen auch
unternehmen aus china und frankreich
beispielsweise tüfteln an diesem konzept
bis 2020 will die china general nuclear
power group kleine reaktoren mit 100
megawatt leistung in see stechen lassen
und zwar an bord von tanker ähnlichen
schiffen tormann mehr bleibt da nicht zu
sagen vielen dank an technology review
in zusammenarbeit mit der redaktion
dieser ziemlich coolen zeitschrift ist
dieses video entstanden und exklusiv für
dich zum zuschauer habe ich jetzt ein
geschenk ihr bekommt nämlich eine
ausgabe gratis wenn er auf diesen link
hier oben klickt das lohnt sich so
richtig da sind noch mehr hammer themen
drin und hier geht es weiter dafür auch
draufklicken thorium reaktoren die
lösung aller energieprobleme mit
atomkraft bis dann bleibt dran